thank you I am here tonight as I think
all of us are first and foremost as film
fans and to publicly thank Kevin
Brownlow for a lifetime of determination
unswerving preservations
perseverance and uncompromising devotion
in order to make sure that the films
that we love we can see them forever in
the way that they were meant to be seen
so we bow down to you sir Kevin your
devotion to the audience and unshakable
belief in the silent film as an art form
is inspiring and as your fellow
archivists have recently noted your
commitment to absolute perfection in
every aspect of research writing
restoration production and exhibition
has changed film history and influenced
new generations of filmmakers every time
one of them sets out on another flea
market run or a dusty attic or garage
sale in search of that elusive missing
bit of footage the fingerprints of your
own pioneering detective work will be
casting a very long shadow you were
there first and because of that we are
all very lucky indeed the silent greats
that we saw in the previous film are
obviously no longer with us but thanks
in large part to the brilliant and
painstaking efforts of Kevin Brownlow
their immortality is assured so I'm
certain that somewhere tonight chaplain
Lloyd Keaton Chaney Garbo Gish Gant's
DeMille the door and Griffith are in
countless others are lifting a glass and
raising a toast tonight to this
remarkable man and his priceless
accomplishments on behalf of the
Academy's Board of Governors I proudly
present this Oscar with the eternal
gratitude of all those who came before
us and all those people out there in the
who will come after to Kevin Brownlow
come on and get this
you